[Music]
all right welcome to games you should
know by heart because you at home are so
intelligent you memorize lots of chess
games just like the people here now what
I did is I made the games as short as
possible okay so the first game white
played efore and black resigned can you
remember that game you should know that
by heart now that's the game Rufus
versus doofus no I'm kidding
okay that's actually games that are
played downstairs of the Chess Club okay
that's that's as good as they can play
so ie4 I didn't see it coming all right
so this this lecture is gonna be about
two underrated players one of them was
the world champion he's still underrated
and just as hard a world champion you
get no respect okay the first one is
Harry Nelson Pillsbury your favorite
player let's ask a random student Arjun
have you heard of Harry Pillsbury
okay and what tournament did he win that
you've heard of well you've heard of the
city of Budapest but yeah come on
you could just say Budapest cuz it says
Budapest up there you think I'm that
dumb don't answer that
alright let's ask somebody intelligent
in the audience what famous tournament
in pillsbury win I'll give you a hint if
you don't know that's the only one you
heard of no never nothing ok it was
played in 1895 that was a good hint Oh
okay give me another hand it's where I
got married the first time okay I'll
give you another hit you incorrect
no but that's you I lived in Belgium
okay give you another hint there was a
famous battle there in 1066 and smart
audience you got here what's that
Hastings yeah yeah Hastings 1895 was a
famous tournament everybody played I
lectured about I've shown cross tables
from that tournament okay and the winner
of that chairman was Pillsbury also
playing for Lasker steinitz and other
good players and there's a famous game
from that tournament you all know
Steinitz versus Oh
oh you're closed now you were closed
steinitz versus vaughn Bartle even what
does anybody know that game yeah you
know when the rook went to East seven
then f7 then g7 that h7 oh no I've shown
that game like 80 probably that was in
like last week's class oh I would have
put that game in but I figured you'd
know it so I put in games I figured you
didn't know except for one which I just
like too much so I put it anyway so this
is cos Barry win a war and win a war is
the player you may have heard of from
the window our variation of the French
no nothing all right good job okay now
unfortunately players a long time ago
played terrible okay which was good for
Murphy okay he just beat them up okay
they played like you the best players in
the world okay man what an insult say
you and them I insulted everybody I like
that
and occasionally somebody played good
like Murphy and I was about it
however Pillsbury was quite a good
player and he was the best player in the
US for a long time but you've only heard
of Frank Marshall so you're like toes
Barry who's that okay what's that who
know okay
now Pillsbury was white and he played
d4x clam winnow are was black preventing
the window are French pretty good huh no
nothing so they played a semi Slav which
I don't understand because this was the
year 1896 how are they playing a semi
Slav what what is this 2017 what's
happening over here now winnow are
played a variation that nobody good
plays in the last 50 years
except recently deceased American
Grandmaster no more recently than him
that was a good answer yeah very good
the highest rated player in the room got
the instrument
Arthur biz guy recently died and when he
was black in this variation he played
the way winnow are does here but most
people didn't do that most people in
this position play the move the most
common move
ah you making me look bad because he
played Bishop d6 that's the uncommon
move what's that what the highest rated
player in the room was always giving the
radian sir D takes e4 is every game ever
played there are no other games in chess
just this one okay and then there's at
least 8000 Grandmaster games with that
move okay and every grandma Esther's
played it and I don't play the semi Slav
and I've still played it and I'm not
kidding
I like played it once and I got crushed
okay all right so actually I played it
twice and I won the second game forgot
about that
okay so Bishop d6 AB is guy our
specialty castles castles efore are the
correct move everybody takes everything
AB is Geyer specialty take take take
take now I'm not a big fan of Knight f6
because I like the night on d7 because I
think at some point black should play e5
or c5 I'm not sure what theory says but
I came to understand theory it speaks to
like Russian or something okay so 9 f6
I'm not a fan of the bishop just go
somewhere else and now it's harder to
play C 5 and e5 but and also the knight
can get pinned
I don't like 9006 but it's 1896 so I'm
not gonna complain very much ok age six
stopping Bishop g5 h6 recommended by
who's the funniest who can get it
Wow there's a guy who yeah my comer my
comer likes to play h6 one loses a tempo
and gets crushed because he defends ok
that's auspicious of g5 when my comer
plays it why does he play it Arjun no
it's actually another reason Knight g5
it is but he is afraid of Knight g5 like
in the two nights
he's like h6 I move three okay and then
when people on the internet like my
comers the worst I hate my comer okay
and I should stop doing that I mean wait
a minute all right
so pillsbury played Bishop e3 which in
my opinion is the only move of the game
that like nobody would play but it's not
that bad
every other move is like is you know
stockfish 9 every other move is perfect
okay now
Bishop III has a very obvious reason why
he played it that pause defended twice
and not attacked who know as I said
earlier it was about a minute ago so you
forgot black wants to play black wants
to play black wants to play I said it
like a minute ago you guys rewind and
say what I what's that
wants to play c5 or e5 that's why I
don't like Knight f6 I don't think he's
playing e5 you guys might play e5 but
don't don't do it
but c5 makes a lot of sense because you
want to get rid of the center pawn and
eventually this Bishop is very
suspicious so if you could cheat you
would play b6 Bishop e7 c5 and you would
be equal or even better so Bishop e3
makes c5 less good so I think that's why
I play Bishop e3 all right sorry okay
rook e8 Oh rook e8 no that's why we know
why never never knew the price of tea in
China because he played rook e8 no
nothing in smart audience today
okay so Queen d3 so you guys are all
happy right bishop c2 queen d3 yeah you
guys look alright finally Queen c7 now
because he played Queen c7 he's sort of
ready for he's ready for everything
so what move did white make that stop c5
in d5 why would a good player
you guys hear crickets at home what's
that who does that stop either one did
you say Queen c3 you didn't stop either
one well I said stop it both come on man
I'm gonna change her name to argent with
any if you don't want him to play c5 you
got to do it yourself
c5 right now yeah Bishop f8 because I
always play Bishop f8 95 man he's
looking like a good player this looks
like a modern game doesn't like 1800s
there's no King's gambit there's no
sacking 5 pieces there's white getting a
positional edge and squeezing him
that's why Pillsbury was great okay
Bishop takes c5 because it is 1896 so
it's all tactics okay now if Bishop
takes e5 was a good move
that means 95 is a bad move very
insulting to the opponent and you guys
see why he played Bishop takes e5 okay
because the point on d4 is doing too
much okay now as my son and I like to
say
Pillsbury given the sugar me do if you
watch The Simpsons every episode ever
you'll get that okay and he may if you
thought Bishop c5 was a good tactic
you're gonna like this move a lot more
you with the right answer Oh why'd you
make me look bad no ah ah nobody finds
Pillsbury's move Pillsbury was actually
good you have other players in the
1800's I have no comment okay morphe was
good laughter was good sometimes finance
was good sometimes he was not good who
didn't somebody say that I don't
understand IG for somebody explain it to
me so I take it
why English what King f8 94 you lose the
night I take it and I'm Freddie Queen eh
- mate yeah all right so you all played
sacrifices but up the one that he played
that's why we're lecturing about him
these are games you should memorize ok
that was funny somebody said it but I
couldn't hear him
BAM that's what you're gonna play Arjun
why not it's too good don't play Bishop
h6 is too exciting it's a Futurama joke
only Spencer could get it and Lulu okay
so I'm guessing if you take it what did
he do something crazy he took that if
you take it I have no idea what I would
do but I know what I would do I would
play Queen Shaq and then I would win
your queen next move anybody agree with
me I do okay you do so the King has two
legal moves for those of you who think
h7 is legal it's not and then I would
play Knight g6 check and I would take
your queen
okay Pillsbury was good alright so if
you can't take the bishop and I'm gonna
play Queen g3 next move anyway he took
this on D for Queen D for g h6 queen F
for Queen afore was a really good move
now I want to play my queen g3 check and
my other check again and I want to take
your knight
okay now you remember in other lectures
and in other games we were talking about
a free attack and all that kind of stuff
did white sacrifice five pieces now
white sacrificed a pawn and black has
this good defense of his King Oh
terrible right so basically white
sacrificed almost nothing and he says
this monster attack with all his pieces
okay but I'm sure black can defend okay
so 95 attacking this Queen and defending
that Queen that's why that guy has an
opening named after him he's not bad
Queen takes h6 now most of you would
take the knight
and then how would white win other other
than you know the guy who obviously
knows you obviously know to give them a
chance yeah is that right is that right
Arjun yeah this should age 7 that's the
only legal move Bishop g6 that's now if
I was white I would go here because
that's you know I like to torture
m'little but okay check and then mate
and if you do puzzles online this is a
very common theme that they like to do
Bishop 8 yeah okay so you'll see that a
lot okay so when a large didn't fall for
that
so after Queen age six he didn't play
Queen takes tonight
however White has a lot of threats here
White has like seven hundred pieces
attacking the black King and materials
equal okay so he played f6 breaking my
rule never play of six but his Queens
defending h7 and his pawns attacking the
knight now this was shocking to me it
really is I'm like usually I'm kidding
but I'm not kidding I'll be kidding the
next thing I say pills boy played a
really interesting move here that was
really exciting and I was like I can't
be the best to move this is 1896 so I
turned the engine on and it's the best
move I took the engine a while to find
it so pillsbury was good and morphia and
that was it okay
so this is a really I like this move a
lot I thought it was a good move but I
said it can't be that bastard those guys
didn't play the best moves back then so
this move does several things black
wants to play pawn takes Knight and
white wants to get more pieces into the
attack so it actually prevents F takes
e5 and threatens to get more pieces in
the attack it's an aggressive move I'll
give you a lot of hints I'm trying
probably not enough hints right that's
right this is one of them yeah yeah he
played f4 I'm like f4 that can't be the
best move but it was so now if Y could
sheet he would probably do that and then
I would like white okay and if black
takes we can throw this check in
threatening the rook
so you would defend your ruck and then
now you're like Oh F for I like that
move now what do you think Arjun Arjun
is like I'll take white yeah yeah now
the Smackdown and the beatdown are
coming so a lot of stuffs coming okay so
when Omar didn't like any of that so he
played rookie 7 and the game ended in
one move
I guess Pillsbury was good and then he
played a move and black resigned and
resigning was the best move according to
the engine and I talked about this with
my private students it's very important
in chess that you defend the back rank
that way you don't get back rank mated
and black just undefended the back rank
see I gave the answer why I'm such a
nice guy
anybody Bensimon these Ben Simon's all
over that yeah
now we're threatening Queen f8 and Queen
h8 the truth hurts however black Ghatak
did a good job developing these pieces I
think the computer announced is like
really quick made here I guess I could
play Queen b6 check and Queen g1 check
you know avoiding mate yeah otherwise
mates really quick right so that's one
of my favorite games because I never saw
before today and I was like wow
Pillsbury was good now I'm from Michigan
as you know I mean you know it now
you knew it for obvious reasons and
there's a guy in Michigan you've never
heard of named Nick Pope he's I don't
know B player
I actually don't know I think he's a B
player and he wrote a book on Pillsbury
so if you want to buy a book on
Pillsbury has a whole book on Pillsbury
good book and basically when people
think of top american players they think
frank marshall and a lot of people don't
know about Pillsbury and some of them
know about Showalter we have a show of
hands about show alter
you've heard of Showalter that's it what
about you your master yeah
he's like Showalter we talking about
Showalter was like you know top 20 in
the world he was like number two or
three in America forever
oh I'm furious anyway he was no
pillsbury but you know that takes the
cake
okay so Pillsbury was good and he was an
underrated player people at the time
knew how good he was he won a Steve's
1895 he was the best player in America
but people today are like that was over
a hundred years ago give me a break you
heard a last we heard Stein it's come on
get give me a break Lasker and Steinitz
came in like fifth and seventh and
Hastings and Pillsbury won so I don't
want to hear any of it okay now the next
two games are by the same player and he
was a world champion he's underrated
he's mainly underrated in this country
I'll tell you how underrated he is I'm
shaking my head because it happened last
week I'm ashamed to be an American you
know I'm talking about you don't know
were talking about I'm teaching a chess
camp the advanced camp you could delete
that if any of the parents are watching
and I said you know which world champion
blah blah blah barrack and world
champion America will champion Bobby
Fischer and I'm like right and there
were 23 kids in the camp and I said whom
did he beat to become world champion and
then they guessed for like an hour and
the class ended they were like you know
Kasparov I heard the first answer was
Morphy that was the first answer the
second answer was Kasparov then they
just started naming random people and
well you Bensimon me okay some kids like
me like not you okay then they were like
you know the server over there look at
it no okay and then when I said Boris
Spassky there was these little really
loud crickets and I was like how they
get in here and I think one kid hurt his
Foskey I didn't like 2:23 that was
furious because spa ski in the US is
known as the guy who lost a Fisher like
a Fisher beat him
okay so West Arjun who's laughing
whom did Spassky beat to become world
champion he's like wait ask somebody
else
yeah there you go yeah you heard of him
yeah there you go right heard of
Petrosian but not spitting a year's
basket okay
so coincidentally when I was looking at
games to memorize I was looking at
Spassky games because Spassky was good
and this is a famous game you all know
it and you can memorize it because it's
short that's like your only hope this is
against bent Larsen and this is a very
funny story as you all know that means
they don't know in the USSR back there
against the rest of the world they had a
mansion 1970 in the top two wards for
the rest of the world were you in 1970
it must have dug them up anybody else
want a real answer what's that
Larsen and Fisher and a 1970 Fisher was
better than Larson Fisher was always
better than Larson maybe when Fisher was
like 12 Larson was better probably yeah
once Fisher was 15 or 16 No
then probably Fisher well definitely at
20 Fisher was better between 15 and 20
is arguable okay but a 1970 like Fischer
won like a thousand games in a row
against everybody so ridiculous I know
his 71 don't give me any of that so
Larson said I want to be bored one rawr
and Fisher said okay what Fisher was the
craziest person who ever lived and he
was like yeah you could be bored one
okay and this was one of the games he
played on board one now you're gonna see
who was better a lot of senator Fischer
and it wasn't
now Larson actually did well on board
one so but this was the game he didn't
do well so this is the famous game
because I'll show you a position and
I'll tell you something really funny
about it
okay so Larson played b3 and I play b3
occasionally and I'm like oh I play b3
and so does Larson I'll look at Larson's
games and I'll play like him but then I
looked at Larson's games and I'm like
I'm not
like him play b3 but he was always like
lost in the first time moves that he
would anyway
okay Spassky plays he five because he's
Spassky he always plays in the center
develops a different piece every move
Knight f3 is a weird movie for and
resigns okay so you remember that game
games to memorize all right 94 Spassky
develops another piece amazing 96 takes
III Bishop f5 how can we like I move
seven and black has all his pieces out
and his opponent has one what this is
what I'm so furious
okay Queen c2 which I would never even
think of that was like the game I showed
in the last class not this one and then
white play Queen c2 I was making fun of
it very similar to this oh that guy one
okay Queenie seven cuz we're gonna
Castle long hey Castle long so where I
move nine and black did everything
whatever I teach to do in the opening
blagged it all of it okay Castle got all
his pieces out as space in the center
has a real kind open file and white did
nothing why should be ashamed of himself
games almost over so don't blink okay
Larsson lost more time cuz he's not
enough behind in development yeah I
gotta lose some more time so he played
f4 boo
okay weakening everything horrible okay
that's the losing move Knight g4 and now
if it was blacks move
I think every sacrifice on e3 wins I
think Queen h4 wins so he played g3
which does stop Queen h4 I'll give him
that and it allows h5 with the idea of
right unless you're Isaac then you move
your age apart then you forget about it
that was the last class but you might
have missed it it's also the a file
Canadian okay so h5 to play h4 and
Larsson played h3 and said you can't
play h4 showed him
taught him a good lesson so black played
h4 yeah it's funny h3 makes h4 stronger
but does sac apiece but white has good
development I mean no development that's
what I meant
and now Larsen surprised everybody by
castling kingside no Argent's like wait
a minute I know you're kidding now all
right
so you take a piece because that's what
yessir said if you're gonna get made it
might as well be a piece up okay
tanks threatening rook takes h1 with
advantage so I'll rig g1 yeah so in this
position I show it to one of my students
and he looked at it for an hour which
was great because I get paid by the hour
yeah you said the one very good okay and
at the end of looking when he couldn't
find the answer he said well I know it's
not this move then now then he's right
yeah no he said is definitely not that
move but I'm like right that's the move
that's why Spassky was better than him
he was some guy getting awesome and
Spassky was some guy being the world
champion so what move is it not it's not
rookie h1 right and my students
suggested every legal reprove on the age
sponson well it's not work h1 and I said
that's right rook h1 and he was like
1900 and he's like what h1 yeah you know
your pawn plays Rick h1 and he's the
world champion you're like man this
isn't going well for me yeah now you
guys see the threat yeah good job ok and
span and Larson played the move you
wouldn't play oh wait he did that next
move I'm supposed to memorize these
games but I forgot maybe he just took
yeah he took eh oh ok
and after the obvious move the g2 now he
played a funny movie uh Larson I thought
it was funny I mean you could resign
because you can't let the guy play
now he castled now okay you can edit
that out because I'm alright so you
can't move the rug vertically cuz g1
queen is good and he played the funny
move rook f1 because he tried to castle
but it was illegal so he had to play
rook f1 right Arjun okay so if he plays
rook g1 which is a little more obvious
okay then what is black do okay then
this is legal I wasn't gonna play Queen
H when I was gonna play Queen f2 but
your moves better so yeah I agree with
that kid yeah and what do I like to say
the truth hurts yeah I mean if I was
white here the truth would hurt I'd be
like I guess Spassky is better than me
maybe Fischer should have played board 1
ok
so he played rook f1 Queen h4 King d1
the G takes equals Queen and now Larsen
broke the most important rule right but
what should he have done always play
Bishop f1 but he resigned if he takes
then Bishop g4 check and then maybe he
was right to break my rule because of
Bishop e2 checkmate with advantage and
this is even worse exactly
I think this is worse right so remember
he played board one over Fisher okay
now the funny story about Larson because
a lot of people have funny stories about
Larson my good friend Grisha who's
Grisha anybody come on you know Alicia
just Grisha lives in Kentucky
good good hint yeah so KY Donna have
told me once we were working together
he's like oh man Larson's great I want
to play like Larsen this was before I
met him so he looked at all of artisans
games they tried to play like Larsen
that when he kept losing all of his
games he stopped okay now that was like
the worst game ever but Larsen had very
interesting games and playing
interesting is difficult I know you guys
try to do it but you see how you do
so yeah and when Larsen played
interesting in one that was really cool
okay but when he lost it wasn't cool the
game I've never seen before is game when
Spassky was a junior okay and this is in
a junior tournament in Leningrad okay
which no longer exists I don't care okay
if you want to go to Leningrad go to
Florida and go to st. Petersburg play
shuffleboard right Arjun uh-uh
there's two things I hate in this world
people who are intolerant of other
people's cultures and the Leningrad
Dutch we don't get there why you
laughing okay I know you got it
yeah if Arjun got it we're all in
trouble okay so this is spassky's white
and he's playing Rufus or doofus I don't
know I've - nah nah that's cool name
though you got to give him that okay
so spa skis white D for just like in our
first game d5 the Queens gambit accepted
amazing 1949 okay and the skin looks
like I'm white except white played great
but otherwise it looks like the way I
would play this is exactly how I play
okay now if this game was played today
they would trade on c5 and draw every
game it doesn't matter who's playing
Carlsen Giri Anand
kara Juana and they would be begging
each other for a draw and the our border
would say you're not allowed to draw and
they would start crying and finally they
get to King versus King then they would
beg the arbiter for a draw you'd be like
all right it's King versus King and
that's what they do today but this was
1949 Spassky didn't take no smack so he
didn't play dc5 and trade the Queens
that's what they do now because they
don't want to win okay drawing is better
I guess okay or I guess in Carlson's
case losing okay I mean Carlsen Cara
wanna man bunch of losers all right make
sure you leave that in okay so he played
Queenie - no Queen trade I can't have a
memorable game if we have a 90 move draw
in - so Abby five spots key saw his
Bishop was attacked 96 which is probably
inaccurate Knight c3 takes rip d1
pinning the pawn usually in such
positions black plays d3 because that
avoids what happens later although
normally after b5 were not playing nice
e6 so early because we want a fee in
Quetta our Bishop that's why we played
b5 then the Knights blocking it so and
also castling is good I can prove it
White Castle okay and over in that other
room and the advanced camp taught by
that gentleman over there okay
he's like look that guy castled that guy
did and it's probably Greg who did that
lecture but same thing and then when the
guy didn't castle the kids were like who
let him castle then we can draw okay and
Greg's like no let's made him when he
didn't castle and the kids are like
alright now the funny thing is when you
look at super GN games you're like how
come the guy didn't get made it in 12
moves because they Castle and when the
guys gonna man they stopped it but in
junior games when you haven't heard of
one of the players and one of the guys
is the greatest genius ever now it's
like Morphy versus doofus now as you all
know that probably one of you knows it
there was a game played in that room
last year between Wesley so and garry
kasparov
then it was a blitz game right you know
the game I'm talking about and Wesley
sac all his pieces and crushed Apsara
and after the game they said dude what
was that all about and Kasparov said
that was like Morphy versus amateur and
I was the amateur okay and so this is
also gonna be like Morphy amateur except
it's gonna be Spassky amateur all right
so Bishop b7 not playing d3 each takes
d4 White has an isolated pawn so he
resigned because those are weak ok did
black Castle yet is blacks a pawn pinned
so maybe Bishop e7 but I can still play
d5 right so black prevented d5 that
prevents d5 but it's not good yeah so he
played the obvious way to prevent it it
defends d5 7,000 times same thing but
better
yeah night p4 97 blocks your bishop so
then you're never gonna cast it right so
now that black prevents a d5 Spassky
played what is the highest rated player
always right yeah D 5 and also I gave a
lecture once where I showed Karpov games
where he kept losing in this opening
where white played d5
I have 3 Karpov games where his
opponents play d5 in the first 20 moves
and he was dead lost he actually drew
one of them yeah
yes we just left Karpov right yeah very
good
my highest rated player knows everything
all right so d5 and even if it's not
good it's still good write that down
because you see this King is here so
it's good yeah okay and Spassky gets no
credit you just don't for losing to
Fischer you don't know these other games
and when Fischer made his top 10 list of
all time he put Spassky on it okay
because you know Carlsen and Kasparov in
Karpov weren't good yet I mean yeah okay
so he took on d5
Bishop g5 now all of blacks pieces are
pinned just what you want what you
haven't castled right Arjun yeah so now
if it was White's move every move wins
apiece
Bishop d5 95m Bishop f6 all win a piece
true story so Bishop e7 is the obvious
move you unpin and you threaten to
castle this ship f6 which way did he
take let's see how smart the classes
with the Knights with the Knights with
the knight your Knights pinned you give
me your queen away that's thought of
getting to memorize that's the game to
life at night takes rook takes Queen
that's not the Leningrad Junior that's
the st. Louis Archbishop's Junior okay
so Bishop takes also loses a piece
because I just told you did like last
move so cousin there's a pin Bishop
takes f6 Yuri pawns pinned so you can't
you can't do that okay so he played yeah
G takes yeah okay takes takes takes
takes and Black has a great pawn
structure
okay now this reminds you of the game I
mentioned earlier that none of you knew
that guy knows because he's good the guy
who walked and you don't know it's high
rated to me no not you okay
and the game I'm talking about obviously
which reminds you of this position is
sign it's von barter Laban that was
anybody talked about earlier and you
guys are like what are you talking about
that was the game where Stein has played
rookie seven rook F 7 g7 rook age 7 and
then his opponent left I think he had to
go to the bathroom and in that game
earlier in the game Stein has played the
brilliant pawn sacrifice d5 because his
pawn was on d4 and he'd wanted to play
the move when he played d5 his phone was
on d4 because he wanted to play he
couldn't play it cuz his pawn was on d4
but now he could play yeah he wanted to
play 94 but
he couldn't cuz his pawn was there so he
played d5 then he played 94
I wonder Spassky knew that game finance
von Bartoli and what do you think of
course okay
now White's threatening everything 96
and my favorite move knife f5 and
castles makes knight c6 really strong if
you see what I'm saying okay so he
didn't castle but if you don't do
anything
I'll play rook e1 and Knight f5 and 96
and you'll super resign so he broke the
pin and played King f8 now Black's fine
because he broke the pin okay Knight f5
aka
knife f5 okay now one of my favorite
themes which none of you have ever done
but I did it a lot in my game with feed
alcohol AC menace I'm sorry I said it so
bad I apologize okay and is the
overworked theme and I had to give a
lesson today and do two lectures so I
know overworked right you two are it
Arjun okay you can see which pieces
overworked here the black queen the only
black piece that's doing anything it's
defending this red guy and this red guy
the reason they're red is soon black is
going to be embarrassed day so a black
played h5 with the winning attack okay
now you didn't do it to attack he did it
because he was afraid of Queen g4 he was
afraid of Queen h5 he was afraid my
queen was gonna go to h6 in a weird
diagonal way and he played aged five and
said okay I stopped all that I stopped
queen g4 forever
I stopped queen h5 forever I stopped
Queen h6 forever and then space he said
dude nobody's heard of you and I'm gonna
tell you why now
and he played I told you what the answer
was like 10 seconds ago
yeah rook takes d5 yeah and the black
queen is overworked okay
so again the a source erawan theory if
you're going to get mated
I might as well take everything then
you're up some material they took Queen
seven you guys can find the right move
here actually they can't armand yeah by
the way in my camp last week half the
kids would say King g7 the other half
would say rook e8 why are you laughing
when it's true you know it's true
alright so King g8 and why played the
obvious move yeah
now White has some threats such as 97
and Queen g7 although if I was white I
would play h3 to give myself some lift
although h4 is more accurate age 4 is
probably better it fixes the HP h5 those
are important considerations when you're
a GM alright now this is what's funny
it's hard to stop Queen g7 and I think
the engine would either go here or here
I think those are the engine moves yeah
and the other way to stop Queen g7 mate
is rook age 7 yeah but that's not good
right and probably I missed something
better so yeah I told you
yeah you don't see King g8 Queen f5
instead oh oh you're saying in this
position Queen F yeah I missed that yeah
I'm often not a Queen down so I can't
play these positions too well
yeah okay so that I agree Queen if I his
best yeah yeah I agree
so instead of Queen f5 black played yeah
and actually he was playing Isaac and
Isaac Slade did I made him that's the
reverse of what happened anyway those
are games to memorize because they're
not very long and they're really good so
I hope you learned a lot what you should
have learned was Pillsbury's great you
never heard of him so I'm mad at you and
Spassky was better than you thought
see you thought he just lost a Fischer
we did something else not sure what it
was
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]